is there
by way of advice
was funding in your own journey helpful
unhelpful
like is there a right time to get
funding for funding venture funding or
anything borrow some money from your
parents i don't know
like is money get in the way does it
help is the timing important is there
some kind of wisdom you can
give there because you were
exceptionally successful very quickly
funding helps as long as it's from the
right people
that includes yourself and i'll talk
about myself funding myself in in a
second which is like because i can fund
myself doing whatever projects i can do
i don't really have another person
putting pressure on me except for myself
and that creates
strange dynamics right but let's like
talk about people getting funding from a
venture capitalist initially
uh we raised money from matt kohler at
benchmark he's brilliant
amazing guy very thoughtful
and he was very helpful early on but i
have stories from entrepreneurs where
they raise money from the wrong person
or the wrong firm where incentives
weren't aligned
they didn't think in the same way
um
and bad things happened because of that
the border room was always noisy
there were fights like we just never had
that matt was great
i think usu like capital these days is
kind of a dime a dozen right like as
long as you're fundable like it seems
like there's money out there this is
what i'm hearing
um
it's really important that you are
aligned and that you think of raising
money as hiring someone for your team
rather than taking money
if capital is plentiful right
it provides a certain amount of pressure
to do the right thing that i think is
healthy for any startup and it keeps you
real and honest because they don't want
to lose their money they're paid to not
lose their money
the problem you know
maybe i could de-personalize it but like
i remember having lunch with elon it's
only happened once
and i asked him
like i was trying to figure out what i
was doing after instagram right
and i asked him something about like
angel investing and he looked at me with
a straight face and was like why the f
would i do that like why like i was like
i don't know like you're connected like
seems like he's like i only invested
myself i was like
okay you know like
not the confidence i was just like what
a novel idea it's like
yeah if you have money like why not just
put it against your back and like yeah
enable
visiting mars or something right like
that's awesome great but i had never
really thought of it that way but also
with that comes an interesting dynamic
where
um
you don't actually have
people who are gonna lose that money
telling you hey don't do this or hey you
need to face this reality so you need to
create other versions
of that truth teller
and i i whatever i do next that's going
to be one of the interesting challenges
is how do you create that truth-telling
situation um and that's part of why by
the way i think someone like jack when
you start square you have money but you
still
you bring on partners because i think it
creates a truth-telling type environment
um i'm still trying to figure this out
like i like
it's an interesting
it's an interesting diamond so you're
thinking of
perhaps launching some kind of venture
where you're investing in yourself
i mean is that in the books potentially
i'm 37 going on 38 next month i have a
long life to live i'm not definitely not
going to sit on the beach right
so
i'm going to do something at some point
and
i got to imagine i will i will like help
fund it right so the other way of
thinking about this is you can park your
money in the snp and this is bad because
the s p has done wonderfully well the
last year right or you can invest in
yourself and um
if you're not going to invest in
yourself you probably shouldn't do a
startup it's kind of the way of thinking
about it
and you can invest in yourself in the
way elon does which is basically uh go
all in on this investment maybe that's
one way to achieve accountability is
like you're kind of screwed if you're if
you fail
yeah that's
yeah
i personally like that i like burning
bridges behind me so that i'm [ __ ] if
it fails
yeah yeah yeah
it's really important though
one of the things i think mark said to
me early on
that that sticks with me that i think is
true uh we were talking about people who
had left like operating roles and
started doing venture or something he
was like a lot of people convinced
themselves they work really hard like
they think they work really hard and
they they put on the show and in their
minds they work really hard but they
don't work very hard
there is something about lighting a fire
underneath you and burning bridges such
that you can't turn back yeah that i
think you know we didn't talk about this
specifically but i think you're right
there is
you need to have that because there's
the self-delusion at a certain scale
oh i have so many board calls oh like we
have all these things to figure out it's
like
[Music]
this is one of the hard parts about it
being an operator it's like
there are so many people that have made
a lot of money not operating
but operating is just one of the hardest
things on earth it is just so effing
hard
it is stressful it is you are dealing
with real humans you're not just like
throwing capital in and hoping it grows
i'm not undermining the vc mindset i
think it's a wonderful thing and needed
and and so many wonderful vcs i've
worked with
but um
yeah like when your ass is on the line
and it's your money it's
talk to me in 10 years we'll see how it
goes
yeah but like you're saying that as a
source when you wake up in the morning
as uh
you look forward to the day full of
challenges that's also where you can
find happiness
you